attends reste là
toi aujourd'hui je vous emmène à
Marseille à la rencontre d'une
incroyable équipe de recherche
spécialiste des squelettes humains la
bien nommée équipe bons du tout aussi
bien nommé laboratoire ades un
laboratoire CNRS qui se trouve sur le
site de l'université ex Marseille et je
suis super content d'être là parce qu'il
faut que je vous dise que je suis né à
Mexico du coup j'ai grandi entouré de
squelettes humains en papier mâché en
paille ou en sucre et j'ai toujours
senti que ces crânes rieurs et colorés
avaient une histoire
raconter et en vrai même si personne n
couple on est d'accord qu'ici en
Occident la mort et en particulier les
restes humains sont généralement
invisibilisés sauf quand il se
retrouvent au centre de la scène comme
dans un musée une cour d'assise ou un
site archéologique par exemple ici des
chercheurs venus de différentes
disciplines tent de déchiffrer des
histoires contenues dans ces restes
humains qui si elles sont parfois dures
restent toujours
[Musique]
fascinantes j'ai été plongé directement
dans le vif du sujet en rejoignant le
professeur Pascal adalian au service de
médecine légale de la
[Musique]
faculté alors comment vous faites pour
identifier une une personne quels sont
les les différents eos qui peuvent
marquer
[Musique]
l'identité quand on est confronté à une
expertise comme celle-là c'est de se
demander si tous les OSM qu'on a devant
nous sont bien humains la deuxième étape
c'est de se demander s'il y a plusieurs
individus après tout on a des
qui sont séparés les uns des autres donc
pour ça on vérifie s'il y a pas des EAU
en double donc une fois que cette
première phase est faite je passe à
l'étape 2 qui détermine un profil
[Musique]
biologique pour donner le sexe un
individu on regardera le bassin
malheureusement au moment du prélèvement
l'oscoxal de ce monsieur s'est cassé
mais sur le terrain nous avions pu
déterminer que c'était bien un homme
l'espèce humaine est une espèce très peu
dimorphique c'est-à-dire qu'il y a très
peu de différence entre les hommes et
les femmes femmees heureusement il y a
une zone qui est très dimorphique dans
l'espèce humaine c'est le bassin chez
les femmes il y a par exemple une
différence très importante ici au niveau
de ce qu'on appelle la grande échancrure
siatique et on voit que chez les femmes
cette échancrure est très large et très
ouverte et très symétrique par
comparaison sur cet OS masculin cette
même échancrure est plus refermée ici en
forme de cross et plus étroite et puis
il y a une autre zone qui est très
différente aussi entre les hommes et les
femmes cette partie-là la branche du
pubis est chez les femmes très allongé
très étiré alors que chez les hommes on
a une branche supérieure du pubis qui
est beaucoup plus courte et plus massive
on a la chance d'avoir des tibias on
peut les mesurer et on a des tables
statistiques qui nous permettent
d'estimer la taille de l'individu donc
on a un homme d'environ 1,65 maintenant
on va se dire parmi tous les hommes de
40 ans et 1,65 qu'est-ce qu'il a de
particulier pour le
[Musique]
reconnaître ce squelette a des marqueurs
osseux très particuliers qui vont nous
permettre d'estimer une corpulence
importante c'est une pathologie que l'on
retrouve sur ces vertèbres on a sur le
côté droit des vertèbres comme une
coulée de bougie qui est venue les
associer entre elles et cette
pathologie- làà on sait qu'elle est
fréquemment associée avec un Ambon point
et parfois avec un diabète de la
personne ici j'ai une côte vous voyez
cet épaississement auceux là ça c'est la
trace laissée par une fracture de la
côte qui s'est réparée si l'os a eu le
temps de se réparer c'est que c'est
arrivé plusieurs mois ou plusieurs
années avant la mort de l'individu ici
on est au niveau de l'articulation de la
hanche du côté gauche toutes ces
réactions osseuses là toutes ces
surproductions irrégulières remanié ce
sont des traces d'une arthrose très
importante c'est quelqu'un qui boit
c'est quelqu'un qui boitait probablement
qui souffrait qui se plaignait de sa
[Musique]
hanche de temps en temps vous pouvez
constater aussi des des traumatismes qui
ont pu être impliqués dans la mort de
l'individu et paser sa vie bien sûr une
application récente a été de
s'interroger sur une fracture de l'os à
l'arrière du crâne le magistrat nous
demander si la personne était tombée
toute seule ou s'il avait fallu qu'on le
pousse donc les biomécaniciens font des
modèles informatiques qui vous
permettent de simuler tout ça et fait ça
de réussir à avoir des des résultats qui
sont assez robustes pour ramener devant
totalement avec un os ré que l'on va
mettre dans des conditions de pression
d'étirement de torsion qui sont contrôlé
par des machines on va produire un
premier modèle puis on va pouvoir
décliner ce que ça donne sur un homme
très grand très corpulent sur un homme
plus petit plus grcile on va pouvoir
faire des centaines de simulations à la
suite informatiquement puis on va rendre
un résultat exploitable au magistrat
c'est pas une équation mathématique qui
nous demande c'est est-ce que il y a une
volonté de casser
[Musique]
on quitte le centre de Marseille pour
plonger dans le passé avec Gael Granier
et Géraldine Carcel qui travaillent elle
sur des squelettes beaucoup plus anciens
alors vous vous êtes archéologue du coup
vous vous intéressez à des squelettes
mais qui sont beaucoup plus anciens
celui-ci il date de quand et comment
vous savez la la la période à laquelle
il a vécu alors celui-ci en particulier
enfin ces deux-là ils datent d'au moins
1600 ans puisqu'ils ont été datés du 4e
siècle de notre ère et on le sait parce
que d'une part les données
archéologiques nous ont permis de le
situer dans les couches qui se sont
superposé au fil du temps et d'autre
part on a réalisé des datations sur le
carbone 14 qui nous ont donné des date
très précise nous ce qui va nous
intéresser en fait c'est de savoir qui
c'est d'un point de vue biologique donc
çair si c'est un homme si c'est une
femme l'âge qu' pouvait avoir au moment
du décès et tout ce qui va en fait
l'affecter dans sa
vie
wou on est où ici là ici on est dans la
partie de l'ostéothèque régionale qui
est accueilli dans notre laboratoire où
sont conservés tous les ossements qui
sont extraits des fouilles de la région
il y en a à peu près combien il y en a à
peu près 10000 ok on a des squelettes
qui vont du néoistique jusqu'au 19e
siècle ok donc c'est un peu comme une
bibliothèque mais avec des OSM on peut
venir emprunter un un squelette non on
peut pas les emprunter mais on peut
venir les étudier doncok quel quel genre
d'information peut avoir on peut faire
déjà des datations donc avec le
radiocarbone on peut faire aussi des
analyses génétiques génomiques sur sur
laadn ancien et on peut aussi avoir des
informations avec les isotopes les
périodes de mobilité qu'ont connu les
individus dans leur vie leur origine
géographique et aussi leur alimentation
leur type d'alimentation à quel type de
ressource ils avaient accès et si il y a
des différences entre les individus au
sein d'une société qui pourrait nous
permettre de comprendre l'organisation
de cette
[Musique]
société vous faites de l'observation
directe mais des fois vous avez d'autres
outil pour pouvoir analyser les les
squelettes c'est quoi ce que tu as dans
la main là alors ça c'est un scan et
pour le coup c'est un scan lumière
pulsée euh qui va directement en fait
sur le crâne projeter de la lumière et
prendre en même temps des photographies
voilà et ça ça nous permet en fait de le
sauvegarder en 3D directement donc il va
s'afficher en même temps et en même
temps d'avoir une sauvegarde à vocation
patrimoniale ne pas druire en fait
l'objet et en même temps de pouvoir
continuer à l'utiliser mais de manière
virtuelle de le diffuser auprès des
collègues de pouvoir en discuter
directement de pouvoir faire des mesures
en fait de manière quasiment aussi
précise que si on le faisait sur l'os
réelle
vous vous travaillez dans le champ des
sciences humaines et sociales en en
anthropologie sociale alors par quel
biais vous abordez cette thématique du
squelette et des osmos humains la chose
qu'il faut garder à l'esprit c'est le
fait que cet osement cet objet bizarre
qui est aussi le reste d'une personne
devient un objet scientifique devient
une preuve judiciaire devient un objet
patrimonial en même temps et du coup ces
usages peuvent donner effectivement lieu
à des conflits à des tensions à des des
oppositions dans l'appropriation dans la
façon de considérer cette objet on peut
prendre un un exemple qui est celui du
génocide commis contre les réos et les
Namas par l'Allemagne en 1905 en Namibie
et donc ces osmans ils sont conservés
par par des universités allemandes
encore maintenant l'état namibien en
2011 a fait une demande de restitution
de ces objets en tant qu'État en
considérant qu'il ne pouvait pas être
des objets de science mais qu'il devait
être considérés comme des biens
patrimoniaux restitués à la namiie en
tant qu'État simultanément les
communautés Nama et Herero ont elles
fait une demande de restitution à
l'Allemagne en considérant que ces
objets étaient non pas des objets mais
des restes d' des restes de parents et
que ces objets devaient être restitués
non pas à la damibi en tant qu'État mais
à ces communautés Nama Herero qui
étaient les seuls légitimes à les
recevoir pour pouvoir les inhumer donc
on voit bien qu'un mêmos peut être
considéré par un pays comme un objet de
science par un autre pays comme un objet
patrimonial par des communautés qui font
partie de ce pays comme les restes d'un
défant et presque des reliques Saintes
donc on a une situation de conflit et de
conflit qui durent extrêmement longtemps
et qui sont susceptibles de durer encore
longtemps sans y penser tous les jours
vous trimbalez avec vous votre squelette
et c'est pas très réjouissant d'imaginer
qu'un jour sans vous il continuera son
trajet sur Terre en emportant avec lui
une partie de votre histoire avec votre
patrimoine génétique l'histoire de vos
ancêtres et vos particularités mais
aussi ce que vous avez mangé ou les
maladies avec lesquelles vous avez vécu
bref une sorte de biographie qui se sera
écrite bien malgré vous après est-ce
qu'il y aura quelqu'un pour la lire va
[Musique]
savoir